hey I do want to remind you that the
president is a [ __ ] and I know you
might hear me say this and say David
what what are you talking about what I
mean is this we've been doing many
policy critiques of Trump and
Republicans the travel ban number one
the travel ban number two the plan to
build the wall the Obamacare replacement
trade policy the budget on and on and on
it's important to prevent the
normalization of the political status
quo under Trump which is that the
president is a truly uninformed [ __ ]
there's really no other way to say it
people aren't going to like me saying
this and to carry out this reminder I've
done this before and people seem to like
it to really see the absurdity and
stupidity of what Trump says it's
sometimes useful not only to hear him
say it but actually to read it so let's
dig into just one example let's dig into
he was asked by Tucker Carlson during a
recent Fox News interview to explain the
whole wiretapping thing ok let's first
watch and listen to the clip and we'll
give our initial impressions so on March
4th 6:35 in the morning you're down in
Florida and you tweet the former
administration wiretap me surveilled me
at Trump Tower during the last election
how did you find out he said I just
found out I don't learn that I've been
reading about things I read in I think
it was January 20th a New York Times
article where they were talking about
wiretapping there was an article I think
they used that exact term I read other
things I watched your friend read there
the day previous where he was talking
about certain very complex sets of
things happening and wiretapping I
should swim it there's a lot of
wiretapping being talked about I've been
seeing a lot of things now for the most
part I'm not going to just because we
have it before the committee and we will
be submitting things before the
committee very soon that hasn't been
submitted as of yet but it's potentially
a very serious situation I want to show
you how truly moronic this non-response
is ok Pat let's put it up on the screen
and this is really the only way to
figure out absolutely how absurd this is
ok again the question was Tucker Carlson
how did you find out about the alleged
wiretapping let's break this apart
piece-by-piece quote well I've been
reading about things I read in I think
it was January 20th a New York Times
article where they were talking about
wiretapping okay number one he says the
New York Times is not trustworthy and
failing now he's saying the New York
Times is his source for wiretapping of
course the New York Times article didn't
say that Trump was wiretapped from
continues ah there was an article I
think they use that term uh I read other
things okay that that's not a source I
watched your friend Brett Bayer the day
previous where he was talking about a
certain very complex sets of things
happening and wiretapping I said you
know there's a lot of wiretapping being
talked about I've been seeing a lot of
things now for the most part I'm not
going to discuss them because we have it
before the committee and we will be
submitting things before the committee
very soon that hasn't been submitted as
of yet but it's potentially a very
serious situation that that's not an
answer there's no answer there when
Tucker Carlson says how did you find out
about allegations that you had been
wiretapped there is not an answer there
it's always really funny when you take
Trump quotes and you type them out like
that and put it on the screen yeah
because he at least has this talent of
wouldn't no matter how ridiculous what
he's saying is yeah he can at least say
with confidence if there he knows what
he's talking about yeah but if you
remove all of that and just see the
plain text there it's clear he has no
idea what's completely abortive yet so
he's saying he frequently heard the term
wiretapping used on TV and thus tweeted
Obama wired tapped him
that's what Trump is saying that's what
he's saying others numerous discussions
about this on our reddit discussion
forum check it out david pakman.com
slash re d di t back after this